the Dow Jones Industrial Average opens
this morning after rebounding from its
biggest points drop in history the index
slump more than 500 points at the start
of trading yesterday but it bounced back
with a 567 point gained by the clothes
the Dow reclaimed almost half of what it
lost in Monday's plunge CBS News
financial contributor Mellody Hobson is
here to sort it all out
Meli welcome back two days in a row
that's that same chair yesterday and
said everybody relax it's gonna be a
bumpy ride get used to it the bump feels
pretty good today it does feel very good
and this is what I'm hearing on Monday
the machines were trading the algorithm
stepped in and as the market was going
down the selling exact was exacerbated
yesterday the institutional investor
stepped in and they were buying on the
dip and that's what pushed the market up
so volatility is something we need to
get used to there's actually since we've
had unusually low volatility it actually
doesn't make sense how low it's been
last year we did not have one day not
one where the market closed down two
percent or more not one day you know
that is just that just doesn't happen if
you look at the years before that five
times it happened four times twenty-one
times in 2011 so we've had this
unusually low volatility period it's
lolled us into thinking that it's gone
away and now we're probably going to see
more volatility so yes get used to it
and give us a framework for
understanding that future volatility is
it because the economy is doing well and
people are worried about interest rates
why is it that and how should people
think about that future volatility well
the reason that they should think about
it is this the natural course of the
market and so up and down days are
normal we went through this period where
literally every day the market was up as
I that famous saying goes trees do not
grow to the sky it doesn't work like
that the market gives the market takes
away over the long term we generally see
an upward March for the stock market
how much your politics impacting the
market do you think they haven't and
that's how you know that is what has
been so bizarre I have to say the market
has just walked off the dysfunction in
Washington they've walked up
it's walked off some of the dysfunction
around the world if you think about it
they have to borrow a trillion dollars
nuclear talks brexit
the looming government shutdown nothing
and so that has actually been an also
unusual and one would have expected some
more volatility from just even some of
the politics or in the rhetoric thanks
Melanie